hey guys kale here community manager for
loadout I'm gonna talk about our new
game-mode annihilation annihilation is
all about team play it combines the
objectives from existing game modes you
already know into one huge battle to
determine who's the baddest mofo out
there any group of eight can play
anihilation exhibition for fun or
practice you need to complete objectives
in order to raise your team score just
like any other game mode but in
annihilation performing well will also
raise your personal score your personal
score functions like a currency that you
can spin on performance injections that
will increase your power for the rest of
the match or if you want to show off
your Slayer skill the Slayer injection
improves your offensive capabilities by
increasing the damage you can dish out
to a judge so if you're feeling too
squishy the tank injection increases the
amount of damage you can take and if you
just want to spread the love the healer
injection will improve the rate your
weapons heal and increase the
effectiveness of health hacks you pick
up so don't forget to upgrade
otherwise you'll be that guy who gets
put in a knapsack and carried by his
teammates there are three objectives
that contribute to your team score and
annihilation controlling activated
capture points not only increases your
team score but buffs one of the
capturing players with a 30 second
damage boost so don't be a dumbass use
it wisely
capturing the enemy's hammer also raises
your team score steal it from their base
and take it to your own but remember you
can only score if your hammer is safe at
your base still protect your every tool
counts provide as you grab the plutonium
body you score points by grabbing the
vials dead enemies drop you denied the
enemy points by snatching the vials your
debt allies leave behind if you don't
grab the vial you don't get the points
so how do you win annihilation first you
have to raise your team score by
completing the objectives scoring enough
points will lower the shield's on the
enemies dropship once the shields are
down it's all about blowing up the
dropship by smashing its power supply
smashing the power supply isn't as easy
as it sounds oh you have to steal the
enemy hammer and charge it at your base
then you must fight your way to the
enemy dropship and smash the power
supply with the charged hammer to
trigger a massive explosion
so give anihilation to try an exhibition
just remember you're gonna have to play
as a team to win